it seemed like there was a lack of
urgency there or something going on
there was a penalty so we were negative
yardage there was a lot of time between
snaps uh well when the penalty happened
and we're behind the chains no no stop
saying but i just told you the clock was
running and we had a penalty you want to
give them the ball back no you don't
play you don't know it
that's just plain and simple
was i happy with the drive no we didn't
score points that's the dumbest question
you could ask
what
jesus
that's baker mayfield earlier this week
interacting with our next guest tony
grocery of espn cleveland we talked
about this at length yesterday i don't
like the whole you didn't play the game
card i i didn't like the rudeness that
was demonstrated there i know baker
mayfield's a fiery guy but uh sometimes
there's a line you don't want to cross
tony grossi joining us now talk about
that and other things related to two and
five browns it's not going to be all
about baker mayfield but tony let me
start right there let's say you were on
the phone right now with baker mayfield
instead of me what would you say to him
how did i get you on the phone
[Laughter]
i would say
hey you have to
direct your anger away from me and to
your uh to your job yeah he he says mike
he plays better when he's angry
um but i think that that uh
that should be uh tunneled towards
sundays not wednesdays of practice week
it does seem to me like he has thrived
off of external doubts external
criticism he keeps a list of everybody
who's ever dissed him and he uses that
to fuel himself and that's fine but if
it leads to moments like we saw on
wednesday it's not fine because
from an outsider's perspective you see
it it's like what's this guy's problem
is that i mean what were you
experiencing
in your own brain as you're watching
baker mayfield interact with you the way
that he did
well i got i thought uh um you know it
was a little out of line uh
how uh
accelerated his anger got
he's picked not picked on me but i mean
he's usually directed some uh snarky
responses to me and i and i just decided
not to to i just decided to challenge
him on this particular point because i
was i was trying to get to a you know
bad execution in a two-minute drive at
the end of the half that could have
gotten them right back in the game it
and those are the
periods of games where the browns are
are really uh
failing at you know pressure situations
that could change the game and so when i
challenged him he didn't like it and i i
either had to say
all right step back or
try to find this answer and he didn't
like it
a year ago this week freddy kitchens was
the team's running backs coach minding
his own business not on anyone's short
list to ever be a head coach in the nfl
and then he became the interim offensive
coordinator and then he became the head
coach do you think in hindsight he was
prepared and or is prepared for the job
that he now has
well it's hard to defend that it was the
way things are going i i do know that at
the time mike
nobody uh ridiculed the pick i mean
there was questions well let's see how
it goes
um and and and he had a short sample
size as coordinator but clearly his
relationship with with baker and their
uh results collectively
over the eight games got him the job and
then there was a leap of faith after
that but
the way they worked together and the way
things seemed to be going uh they didn't
want to lose freddie
and yet
it didn't seem they could pair him up
with an experienced head coach to keep
them as coordinators so they decided to
take the extra step
is there anything to the criticism that
came from former offensive line coach
bob wiley before the season he was in a
radio uh interview and he said that that
basically it was ken zampesey last year
the quarterbacks coach that was the one
responsible for the growth of baker
mayfield and freddie kitchens didn't
have much to do with it and the kitchen
shouldn't have gotten the job and i know
that wiley you know obviously
disgruntled because he didn't get
retained but is there anything to that
that opinion that he shared several
weeks back
again it's almost hard it it's difficult
to say
he was full of it right the way things
are going right now
but
nobody at the time gave zampeezy
much credit
at least within the organization
for the turnaround of baker mayfield
last year and and the author you know
wiley and and ken were were huge acts
and loyalists and and you got bumped out
of the job and and they weren't brought
back
um now again it's it's hard
that freddie is kind of the whole
cleveland browns offense is kind of
playing into that that whole idea that
there's a missing there's a coach
missing that connected it all together
but i i i don't agree with them
it just doesn't explain why things are
going so haywire now
if we applied sodium pentothal both to
john dorsey the gm of the browns and
receiver odell beckham jr would they
both say that if they had to do it all
over again with the trade that brought
him to cleveland they would
i think i think dorsey would i'm not
sure about odell
um
yeah he he's been a
a consummate teammate from everything i
can tell
it's just not going the way they thought
he's the only wide receiver mike with a
receiving touchdown so far
he is leading the team i think in
receptions but all of his numbers are
down
everybody's numbers are down except nick
chop but i think dorsey would definitely
do it again
odell didn't have a choice but uh
he's not kicking and screaming about the
trade
we know that they weren't shopping him
at the trade deadline have you caught
wind of anyone calling the browns and
trying to maybe pry odell beckham jr
away before that window closed on
tuesday
no i i have not i i don't think his name
was bandied about much you know the
problem now i don't know if it's a
problem but his relationship with jarvis
landry is so strong and he does have a
good relationship with o'dell uh i i
would think that trading odell at the
deadline would have would have been a
very disruptive thing to do within the
locker room
uh tony last 30 seconds what would you
say is the primary reason why this team
is at two and five and not living up to
the the expectations that were created
last year
uh the responsibility has to go on the
coaches mike uh they're not a team that
you look at and say
boy that's a world coach team i mean
they they lead the league in penalties i
think they lead the league in turnovers
i mean it's it's their team is infected
with mistakes and that's really
bad you know no coach wants that so they
could still coach him out of it it's got
to start this week but that's the reason
they just beat themselves
every loss
hey tony great stuff as always thanks
for some of your time and we'll talk to
you soon
thanks mike take care
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports